So let's begin with mathematical thinking.
Before we do begin talking about statistics. I
want you to know.
That we will come across. Well, there will be two things.
That you need to be aware of.
That will be an obstacle.
in
our Learning Journey two things will be our obstacles.
One of them is of course the mathematical rotation. I'm sure.
Many of you are attending this session because you've probably
had your try at learning statistics.
You've found some books some blogs some articles and
videos.
That wasn't sufficient. So it's you know what? Let me let me attend this workshop
and maybe I'll have a better luck here. So one is
the mathematical notation. That's one obstacle.
the second obstacle
or the terms themselves
and I'm showing you only your small sample of the many
words that you have either you're seeing on the screen here, but
what I'm trying to
highlight here is this
some of these words
Are words that you have seen?
Or you're familiar with because they're part of
your English vernacular. Now that doesn't matter
if English is your first language or second language or third language, but if
you see these words
You are you would you tend to
associate them with?
words that are used in English in general
and I want you to know that we will come across words that
you already know in English, but you must try to disassociate them
with English because
when you see a word
and I will they will be highlighting a certain way when you see
those words understand that you're looking at a word in
statistics that has nothing to do.
What that word in English for example?
You look at the word.
Moment.
This is one of the tricky one especially for beginners.
He tend to think about time.
Duration that kind of thing it has nothing to do.
With time whatsoever.
Another one is
the word
population
You know we tend to think about people population of
people.
again in statistics
That is a more General meaning.
Okay, now we will get into these definitions of course, but I want to set that.
Set that expectation from now on so you should
expect to start relearning or
unlearning some of the words with which you
are already familiar.